[Musique]
on parle de joseph est bien connue
plongé suite
oui comme il le fait que l'école et il a
du bon mais dans ma tête ça ne bougeait
pas même qui aurait 10 cm de neige en
attendant j'aimerais bien des fois il y
en a pas et dit je vous laisserai alors
des fois on me le dit loi on a la
surprise agréable de le trouver à la
porte mais chez vous oui devant ma porte
devant la porte et nous laisse
[Musique]
je travaille toujours à l'ancienne du
père mixte le yoyo farine sel et une
poussée assez lente
mes clients aiment le teint premièrement
parce qu'il est fait à l'ancienneté
ils se conservent ils n'ont pas besoin
de le congeler
il apprécie le goût je n'y mets aucun
améliorons juste renvoyant relaxe
je prend la vie du bon côté
le jeu ne pense pas le bon moderniser la
fabrication du panache de la continuer
cette tradition le plus longtemps
possible
on met du sel dans le mur du mas et
jamais de l'eau non mais je m'enterre en
othe la farine et embrasse
quand j'étais gosse je travaillais la
ferme je gardais le bétail
quand j'ai eu 16 ans mes parents m'ont
dit il faut partir apprendre un métier
je suis parti et je suis parti pour ce
que mon frère à la propriété j'ai pris
le métier de boulanger ici j'ai fait
trois ans d'apprentissage enseignant de
droit et chez un oncle et ensuite je
suis parti et north bay
[Musique]
les tournées du sort ne suis pas du tout
les clients
vu qu ils sont habitués depuis longtemps
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
par à soupe comme sa jeune clientèle
attitrée
on se pose constamment soit en
conversation nous soit ce qui se passe
soit de noël noël ou wii play où il fait
bon complaisante
on rigole
on se lance quelques blagues
et enfin
[Musique]